واسطه دموع الالاف وصوت اغاني والده تشييع
جثمان وديع جورج وسوف
اخبار علاج ثوري للزهايمر تشغل العالم
وسيد الاكثر حظا في العالم امريكيه فازت
بجائزتين بثلاثه ملايين خلال شهرين اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
من يومين مشاهدينا والحزن والاسى مسيطرين
حول اسم الفنان الكبير جورج وسوف اللي
توفى ابنه وديع في بيروت بسبب نزيف في
المعده على اثر مضاعفات عمليه جراحيه كان
اجراها لتكميم المعده وتم الكشف عن تعرضه
لمضاعفات من بعد العمليه وثلاثه ازمات
قلبيه للاسف كان اخرها يوم الجمعه اللي
فشل الاطباء من بعدها بانعاشو وتم الاعلان
عن وفاته بعضها من دقائق بس تم دفن نجم
السلطان الطرب في مسقط راسه في الكفرون
بمحافظه طرطوس في سوريا وكان في استقباله
اهالي القريه اللي من وقت الاعلان عن
الخبر امتلات شوارعها بصور الراحل وتم
تشيعه من كنيسه مار الياس ووريا جثمانه
العائله
مصارعه مصارعه الاخيره
الله يخليكم يا شباب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قبل الوداع الاخير الراحل وديع جورج وسوف
كان تمت مراسم تشييع في كنيسه القديس
نيكولا اولا في الاشرفيه في بيروت واللي
تم تداول الكثير من الفيديوهات منها
للحظات وصول جثمان الراحل واللقطات
القاسيه جدا بالنسبه لعله
الوداع
الحب نظاره والقلب
قوم الوداع
قلبي الوداع
[موسيقى]
فليت بكير يا خيي
كسرتنا وكسرت قلبي بيك وكسرت قلوبنا كلنا
بيك كان اغلى شيء عندك بالدنيا كان همك بس
يضل مرتاح انت عايش كل حياتك كرماله
لتشوفه مبسوطه مرتاح
هلا
كل اللي بيعرف بيعرف قد ايه قلبه طيب
بيعرف قد ايه خدوم قد ايه بيحب العالم ما
بيطلب طلب اللي يقول له غيره بفكر بغيره
وما بيفكر بحاله صاحبه صاحب نحب بيحب الكل
وبيساعد الكل
مشاهد قصيره جدا
الكبير جورج وسوف الله يرحمه طبعا ويعطيهم
الصبر والسلوان على كل حال مشاهدينا
الفنان جورج وسوف وعائلته من امبارح كانوا
بداوا في استقبال المعزين بالاشرفيه في
بيروت وتوافد الكثير من النجوم والفنانين
لتقديم العزاء وامتلات من الصوت بالصور
والفيديوهات اللحظات وصول الفنانين
واللحظات المؤثره بينهم وما بين سلطان
الطرب جورج وسوف
[موسيقى]
اتصل
على الله
[موسيقى]
وايضا مشاهدينا من بين الفيديوهات اللي تم
تداولها بشكل كبير فيديو مؤثر جدا جورج
وسوف وزوجته
ايوه
مشاهدينا وديع هو الابن الاكبر لسلطان
الطرب ووفاته جاءت بعد عمليه تكميم معده
زي ما كنا ذكرنا في احدى مستشفيات بيروت
وصار معه مضاعفات من بعدها ونزيف بالمعده
تعرض لثلاث ازمات قلبيه متتاليه كان اخرها
يوم الجمعه اللي يعجز الاطباء عن انعاشوا
وللاسفه
واكدت محاميه العائله انه ما في اي ليله
دخلت اجراءات قانونيه ضد الطبيب وانه ابدا
ما تم الحديث عن الاخطاء الطبيه وانه
العائليه بتعتبر هذا الوقت للحزن فقط
[موسيقى]
ننتقل المشاهدين على موضوع اخر وهو موضوع
طبي الالزامره والزهايمر هو مرض عصبي يؤدي
لتقلص الدماغ وموت خلاياه من ابرز اعراضه
فقدان الذاكره هو المسبب الاساسي
55 مليون شخص في العالم وكل سنه في عشر
ملايين اصابه جديده فيه وكل ثلاث ثواني
يتم تشخيص في شخص جديد بهذا المرض
احصائيات مخيفه بصراحه وارقام عاليه
بتخليه لما يكون في خبر عن دواء للانسايمر
بيكون الخبر من اهم العناوين حول العالم
خاصه وانه اليوم العلم والطب ما توصلوا
لعلاج لهذا المرض حتى وقتنا الحالي وكل
الادويه اللي بتنعطى لمرضها ما بتتعدى
كونها مجرد ادويه لعلاج الاعراض ومش علاج
للمرض نفسه الخبر الجديد اليوم هو انه
اداره الاغذيه والعقاقير الامريكيه
المعروفه باسم الاف دي اي اجازه دواء جديد
بيحمل امال لمرضى الزهايمر واعتبره اط او
علماء خطوه ثوريه نحو علاج المرض دواء اس
الدواء عفوا اسمه لكنبي وهو من انتاج
مجموعتي الادويه اليابانيه والامريكيه
بايوجان واثبت العقار بحسب الاف دي ايه
قدرته على اطاء تدهور المعرفي للمرضى
وتحديدا اللي ما وصلوا بعد لمراحل
المتقدمه من المرض تجارب اجريت على 1800
مريض على مدى 18 شهر واثبت الدواء انه
المرضى اللي اخذوه خفض التدهور المعرفي
عندهم بنسبه 27%
ويؤخذ العقار الجديد عن طريق الوريد مره
كل اسبوعين على كل حال هذا الدواء هو ثاني
علاج في العالم للزهايمر همم
اداره الاغذيه والادويه والعقاقير
الامريكيه وهو اول دواء او اول دواء
اجازته كان اسمه
واجازته من سنه ونصف تقريبا وقتها اثار
جدل وانتقداتها كبيره
خصوصا اجراءات اجازته واعراض جانبيه الو
كان الدواء من انتاج طبعا نفس الشركتين
الي اليوم بطوروا هذا الدواء الجديده وهذا
دواء كمان مش بعيد عن مرمى الانتقادات
والمخاوف على فكره خاصه مخاوف تتعلق
بالسلامه مثل علاقته بتورم الدماغ وكمان
النزيف وخاصه لانه مثل الدواء الاولاني
حاز على ما يعرف بالاجازه السريعه وهذا
عباره عن برنامج
الموافقه السريعه على العلاجات اللي
بتكافح الامراض الخطيره اللي لم يتم
التوصل لادويه شافيه لها بعد ومن وقت
الاعلان عن الخبر الناس او تحديدا
المختصين واللي عندهم مرضى الزهايمر كانوا
بانتظار الافصاح عن تكلفه العلاج لانه
دائما تكلفه مهم جدا تخيلوا الشركه
المنتجه اعلنت انه تكلفته
26,500$ سنه
معقول نوعا ما لما بسعر العقاري الاول
اللي تمت اجازته من سنه ونصف وحكينا عنه
واللي كان سعره تخيلوا قد ايه 56,000
دولار في السنه يعني اللي ما معه فلوس
خلاص راحت عليه المتابع للمنصات وتعليقات
راح يلاقي في اسئله تكررت اكثر من غيرها
اولا تساؤلات عن معنى التدهور المعرفي
اللي بسهم الدواء في تراجعه عند المصابين
في المرض امم احد ابرز كمان الاسئله
الانتقادات الموجهه له اسبابها والمخاوف
منه وكمان اسئله عن تكلفته واخيرا ايضا
تساؤلات عن مدى كونه فعلا خطوه فوريه في
علاج المرض ولا لا على كل حال للاجابه على
كل هذه الاسئله لازم نسمع من مختصر عشان
هيك معناها عابر
زومبا بخيت استشاري امراض المخ والاعصاب
اهلا فيك دكتور معنا في تفاعل قبل بدايه
هذا الدواء الجديد اللي اجازته
خلينا نف اكتر عنه شو بيعمل بالضبط ليش
اعتبروه ايضا خطوه فوريه في علاج الالزامر
للي هلا ما له علاج
هذا الدواء الجديد هو عباره عن الدواء
بايولوجي او جسم مضاد هو من كلونا
الانتبودي يعني
مضاد وحيد المسيله ثم يسمى بالعرض
كل الادويه السابقه كانت مركبات كيميائيه
الان الزهايمر هو عباره عن مرض يتسبب فيه
ترسب نوع من نوعين همم من البروتينات همم
وليس كل من يعاني النسيان او يعاني الخرف
هو مصاب بان زهايمر الا الدواء الاول
يعني وجه لبروتين يسمى الضوء وهو يغلف
الغرفه الداخليه العصبيه اما الدواء
الجديد فهو اا لسنه يعني الانتربول
اسمح لي دكتور انت عم تحكي كثير بمصطلحات
طلبيه بنحاول نبسط الموضوع شويه عشان انا
افهم المشاهدين يفهموا اذا ما كان في
عندنا خلفيات طبيه
المضاد يعني
زيك في حالات الاصابات يعني لما يطلع
الباكس انت تطلع مضاده تقتل الفيروس هذه
الاجسام المضاده تعمل ترسيب للبروتين الذي
يسمى البيتا هذا البروتين يترسب بين خلايا
الذاكره يمنع خلايا الذاكره من اداء عملها
وتبدا في الضمور هذا الموضوع همم
الذي يعرف بالدواء ال- همم
هو ان يزيح هذه الترسبات يجعل الخلايا
تعمل بشكل
ممكن يعتبره علاج فعليا لا الزهايمر مش
علاج للاعراض او منع الى التدهور اذا كان
بيشيل هدول الترسبات اللي بتسبب الالزعيمر
اصلا معنى ذلك انه الزعيمر ممكن يصير
ريفير نقدر يعني انه يعني وكانه لم يكن
نعم ااا اذا كانت في الحالات
الاوليه والمتوسطه وليس في الحالات
المتقدمه الان في الحالات المتقدمه تكون
هذه الخلايا قد تلفت والبروتينات قد ترسبت
لا يمكن
لجسم مضاد ان يزيل
في البدايه فهو نجح يعني في ازاالته وفي
تعافي 27% من الذين كانوا في الدراسه
وهو امر يعني
ايجابي
وفعاله
بالتجربه اللي عملوها او التجارب اثبت
فعاليته بنسبه 27% هل نسبه عاليه يعني
ممكن نعتبر انه يعني فعلا هذا علاج ثوري
ام انه ماذا بالضبط
واحصائيه يعني كانت يعني فعاله جدا لانها
هذه السجن كما يقولون
لا يمكن الان تطوير هذا العلاج انتاج اكثر
من مضاد حتى تزداد يعني
النسبه طيب دكتور هو معروف انه كل شيء
مثلا جديد في السوق بكون سعره عالي لما
ينزل وبعدين السعر
اقل هل نقدر نفسر موضوع ال ال السعر
العالي جدا لهذا الدواء 26 الف ولكن او
27,000 ولكن مقارنه ب 56 للدواء اللي قبله
فهل راح نشوف تراجع في تكلفته وليش هالقد
تاكله وفرق كبير ما بين الجيل الاول منه
الجيل الثاني او الدواء الاول والثاني
التكلفه العاليه بسبب انه دواء بايلودي
ويحتاج في صناعته الى تقنيات عاليه من
الهندسه الوراثيه ومن تركيب الجسم المضاد
ومن تنقيته والتاكد يعني من انه يعني
مصنوع بطريقه سليمه لان هذه الاجسام
المضاده هو تعتبر بروتينات
وعندما تدخل الى الجسم اذا لم يكن بدرجه
نقاء عاليه ومصمم بطريقه هندسيه عاليه في
الجسم يمكن ان ينتج مضادات لهذه المضادات
فلا تعمل لذلك
انتاجها صعب جدا بعكس
الكيميائيه الادويه الكيميائيه لا تستحي
بهذا المناعه فلا ينتج لها مضادات انتاجها
ارخص اما الفرق بين الدواء الاول في
بدايته كان ظاهر التكلفه
ولكن بعد ذلك يعني
تصبح تصبح اقل شكرا جزيلا
نتمنى انه يعني ال ال سعره يكون في متناول
الجميع عشان الكل يقدر يستفيد من هذا
العلاج الثوري شكرا جزيلا لك البروفيسور
معاذ بخيت استشاري امراض المخ والاعصاب
العائله المالكه البريطانيه بتمر بازمه
يمكن تكون الاكبر في تاريخها والسبب
الاميره
بطريقه همم
ما حدش عارف ليش ولكن طرحت للبيع بنسختها
الاسبانيه وبدا نشر البلاوي اللي فيها
سلسله من الاتهامات والفضائح والذيعات من
قبل اسرته
خلونا او خلوني استعرض لكم مشاهدينا سريعا
ابرز ما جاء في المذاكره
هو قال انه اخوه الامير وليام في خناقه
مره ضربوا وطرحه ارضا خلال خناقه بينهم
بسببها ما كان في 2019 وقال انه هو واخوه
توسل وابوهم الاميره تشارلز ما يت كامله
وقال كمان انه ابوه كان بيغار من زوجته
وكاثرن زوجه وليم وانهم بيسرقوا منه
الاضواء وانه هو مش مستعد يتكرر يكرر هذا
الشيء او يتكرر هذا الشيء معه في اشاره
لشعبيه والدته الراحله ديانا واللي صار
معها من قبل طبعا الاهتمام الصحفي فيها
وقال كمان انه سبق وتعاطي المخدرات
والحشيش في مراهقته وفي شبابه وكشف انه
قتل 25 عنصر من طالبان خلال عمله في سلاح
الجو وخدمه في افغانستان هو وصفها بانها
اشبه بازاحه قطعه شطرنج من على اللوح هذا
غير طبعا تفاصيل دقيقه عن فقدانه
العذريتهم اكبر سنا في حقل لما كان عمره
17 سنه ايه بس
تفاصيل كمان عن حضوره ولا تصوير مشاهد
حميميه لما كان في مسلسل سوق
مذكرات الامير هاري هاي بنحكي عنها او
بنحكى عنها منشور وشهور وكان في كلام عن
مطالبات وضغوط من قبل العائله المالكه
لوقف نشرها كمان كان في تقارير تتكلم انه
نفسه فكر في وقت نشرها بعد وفاه جدته
الملكه من حوالي اربعه اشهر عموما امام كل
هذه الفضائح القصر للان ملتزم الصمت وما
اصدر اي تعليق رسمي لكن الامير هاري مش
شكله ناوي يهدي اللعب ففي مش مقابله واحده
بالبيئه اكثر من مقابله تحديدا ثلاث
مقابلات منتظره له نزلت الاعلانات
الترويجيه لها ومنتظرها هاليومين في اطار
الترويج الكتاب
المتوقع مع عرض كل هذه المقابله
مجددا لا تويتر والخبر اللي ما راح
تتفرجوا في لانه سمعنا مثله كثير للسنه
الماضيه
3700 موظفين نوفمبر 2022 ولا لا طبعا هو
مش سائل ابدا بالانتقادات اللي بتعرض لها
بسبب هذا الموضوع اليوم
لندنغافوره من العاملين في فريق الثقه
والامان اللي بيتعامل مع الاشراف على
المحتوى العالمي
بالوحده المتعلقه بخطاب الكراهيه والتحرش
وفي تبرير للشركه لعمليات التسريح الجديده
قالت رئيس قسم الثقه والامان في تويتر في
ايميل انه الالاف من بيعمله ضمن فريق
الثقه والامان على الاشراف على المحتوى
واللي بيقوم بهذا العمل يوميا وهدول ما
طالتهم التسريحات اض انا باع تخفيضات
العمال اجرت في مناطق تفتقر للعدد الكافي
للمضيق قدما او حيث يكون من المنطق ضمها
لا مكاتب اخرى وبنبقى كمان في اخبار تويتر
ولكن هالمره في طرح مزايا جديده اعلن عنها
السيد تويتر ايلول ماسك واللي اعلن في
تغريده عن قرب طرح مجموعه من الميزات
الجديده اللي كثر الحديث عنها مؤخرا
الميزات الجديده بتضمن تنقل سريع وسهل
يمين ويسار ما بين التغريدات المقترحه
وتغريدات الحسابات المتابعه ونميزه هاي
منتظره لاحقا هذا الاسبوع بالاضافه الى
الجزء الاول من اصلاح شامل لواجه المستخدم
ماسك اعلن كمان في تغريدته عن زر بوك
معاكي لتغريدات واللي بتمكن المستخدم من
حفظ تغريدات معينه لسهوله الرجوع اليها زر
مثل اللايك يعني بس
ما بين يعني بس ما بين سايلنت عند حدا اما
الميزه الاخيره فهي ميزه جدليه وعليها
كلام كثير وهي ميزت تغريدات الطويله وهذه
ماسك وعد فيها من اوائل
في امريكا في سيده اسمها كينيا
تستحق عن جداره لقب السيد الاكثر حظا في
العالم او خلصنا المحظوظ محظوظ يعني
عمرها 40 سنه وبتشتغل مديره لاحد فروع
مطاعم الدعاء الشهيره ربحت في اغسطس
الماضي جائزه نصيب قيمتها مليون دولار لكن
هذا لحاله مش راح يكون سبب
فبعدنا فازت بمليون دولار بشهرين بس
السيده رجعت فازت بجائزه نصيب ثاني وهاي
المره الجائزه قيمتها مليونين دولار
متخيلين ثلاث ملايين دولار في ظرف شهرين
يعني الله يكمل يكملها بعقلها للسيدات
واللي بيزيد اكثر واكثر انها كشفت انه
الجائزتين المنفصلتين كانت اول مره
بحياتها بتشارك فيهم لما فازت هذا الحجر
الصراحه زي ما بنقول الست كشفت انه هي
بنفسها مش مصدقه اللي معها ولا حتى
قرايبها واصحابها مصدقين بطاقه ال 10
دولارات ربحتها مليون وبطاقه العشرين
دولار ربحتها مليونين اما كيف ناويه تصرف
الملايين كشفت انه بعد الجائزه الاولى
بدات تعمر بيت احلامها وقربت تخلصوا الان
وقالت انها صار لها 15 سنه بتحلم انها
تمتلك منزل والمليون دولار الاولى هذا
الحلم اما الجائز الجديده فناويه تفتح
فيها مطعم
هذا مشاهدينا وصلنا على ختام حلقه تفاعلكم
لهذا اليوم نرقم في الغد باذن الله الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]